When The Twilight Saga was at its height,
it seemed like Taylor Lautner was set to become
one of Hollywood's biggest stars…but then
it didn't really turn out that way.
Here's what may have happened.
Faded hype
Lautner's Twilight co-stars Kristen Stewart
and Robert Pattinson were clever with their
careers.
While still attached to the franchise, they
both starred in other films, like Adventureland
and Water For Elephants.
As a result, the duo likely had an easier
time transitioning to other roles post-Twilight.
Lautner, however, had only a bit part in Valentine's
Day to hold him over until the franchise was
over.
A source told The Hollywood Reporter,
"It's not easy to move out of the shadow of
a hit like Twilight.
But he's still very young.
There's time for Taylor to become more than
just Jacob."
Box office bomb
Lautner was the marquee name in 2011's Abduction,
but the movie didn't do well… at all.
The film was critically panned and earned
a humiliating 4 percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
That wouldn't be so bad if the box office
numbers were better, but the flick made only
$28 million dollars domestically, not even
breaking even on its $35 million budget.
An agent told The Hollywood Reporter,
"His first movie just wasn't very good, and
it didn't justify what he was asking for at
the time."
"I'd be lying if I said there was no pressure
involved.
But you know, I just try and stay focused
on what I can control."
Too expensive
Studios just don't think Lautner is worth
the money he asks for.
A source told Vulture that Lautner's talent
agency...
"... [did] a brilliant job of convincing Hollywood
that he's the next big movie star, but didn't
convince audiences of the same."
Lautner demanded $5 million dollars for Abduction.
When that bombed, studios could no longer
justify the $7.5 million he asked for to star
in Stretch Armstrong and the whopping $10
million to star in the re-telling of the Biblical
David and Goliath.
Both movies were shelved indefinitely.
Four years after Abduction, Tracers was Lautner's
second attempt at a leading role.
Unfortunately, the film never even got a U.S.
theatrical release, and the reviews from those
who actually did see it were not good.
The Ridiculous 6
Lautner seems to have gotten in tight with
Adam Sandler, landing a bit part in Grown-Ups
2 and a supporting role in the Netflix film
The Ridiculous Six.
Unfortunately, The Ridiculous Six not only
scored a whopping 0 percent on Rotten Tomatoes,
but also happened to stir up a lot of controversy
over perceived racist jokes.
Lautner would probably do well to just leave
that one off of his resume.
Passion project
In 2016, Lautner took on the film Run the
Tide, an indie drama with no budget and no
big studio backing.
It couldn't have been further from his Twilight
roots or his attempts at becoming an action
hero.
Lautner described the film in a Metro interview
as a passion project for everyone involved.
Unfortunately, reviews were dismal.
The A.V.
Club labeled it:
"...bargain-basement schmaltz, too blandly
folksy even for Sundance."
...and the Young Folks claimed:
"...the emotion felt forced and it lacked
authenticity."
The review even zeroed in specifically on
Lautner's performance, saying that
"...he just isn't very believable, as much
as he tries to be."
Is it any surprise that Lautner seemed to
take a sabbatical after this?
Taking his time
Lautner has admitted that he'll be pickier
about the roles he chooses moving forward.
When asked by ABC News if he was worried about
being "pigeonholed" by his Twilight role,
Lautner said,
"That's kind of why I want to choose things
that are different."
While he considers his career's direction,
Lautner's really not in any hurry to get back
on a movie set.
He told Reuters in November 2016,
"For me the biggest thing is just surrounding
myself with people that I love, just spending
time, it doesn't matter what I'm doing as
long as I'm with my friends and my family."
"When I'm not working?
You know, playing sports with my buddies.
Watching The Bachelor."
Focused on love?
Lautner and Billie Lourd met on the set of
Scream Queens, and their onscreen romance
spilled over into real life.
According to People, Lourd and Lautner's rumored
relationship began in December 2016.
Lourd's uncle, Todd Fisher, said the relationship
was as serious as it was adorable, telling
E! News,
"He's stepped up and acted like a husband
would act.
Not that that's what's going on, but it's
just an amazing support system for her, and
I'm glad he's in her life."
However, by July 2017, Lourd and Lautner were
over as a couple.
Is it possible that Lautner had pressed the
pause button on acting for this romance?
Work reunion?
One of the brighter spots in Lautner's career
has been the gamble he took replacing Andy
Samberg's character on the BBC comedy Cuckoo.
He was playing completely against type, but
he apparently nailed it.
According to The Telegraph, Lautner was:
"...very good indeed."
Series co-star Greg Davies also had nothing
but praise for Lautner, hinting to Metro in
November 2017 that they may work together
in the future.
He said,
"It's an unlikely friendship.
We're doing two more series next year.
I get on really well with him.
He's a thoroughly decent chap."
Granted, that's not a confirmation that Lautner
is on board, but it sure seems like he's got
an open invitation and a critically-lauded
avenue to pursue should he choose to accept
it.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!